Luang why did you call your book first
they killed my father
Wow though my sister I had a sister that
passed away and died from starvation
my father's death affected me
tremendously and I wanted just to put it
out there I wanted to put it out there
that that's what happened to us first
and then it went on after that it worse
his photograph from but you have enough
cover your book this is a picture of me
when I had just got off the boat in
Thailand um in the refugee camp and they
snapped that picture of me as we were
going in and giving us a number so
that's ten years old just off the boat
in Thailand what year did you come to
United States 1980 and where did you
come when you first got here
Essex Junction Vermont it's um I
remember being in the refugee camp and
there were people going in and was
trying to tell us what our new home was
going to be like and then mostly
missionary people and one of the way
that they did that with some they would
bring in movies and show it to refugees
and the movies like me it's Asia were
all took place in elder Ida la San
Francisco and New York and um and then
we landed in Essex at what age I was 10
years old and how long have you lived
there I was in um in Vermont until about
93 and then I left and moved to me bit
more diversity um and in 97 and muti DC
and what kind of a college degree did
you get where hmm I have a political
science Bachelor in political science
but st. Michael's College in Vermont I
want to go into a rough part of this
book only because I know as I read the
book this this stopped me and and it's
brutal but I want to read a little bit
of it anyway you say the old woman's
hands shake as she raises the hammer
high above her head and brings it
crashing down into the prisoners skull
he screams a loud shrill shrill cry that
Pierce's my heart like a steak and I
imagine that this maybe is how Paul died
where are we in this
at that point the Vietnamese had invaded
Kimbo in 79 and I am staying with my
brother Xin and sister at a internally
displaced camp and internally displaced
people's camp that the Vietnamese were
setting up they had caught a Pol Pot or
a Khmer Rouge member the Vietnamese had
put him in prison but the people rioted
in demanded his release and they
actually in the end the viennese soldier
gave him over to the people and they had
a public execution they had a public
stand I was um nine years old now I
witnessed my first public execution and
you also write the soldiers head hangs
bobbing up and down like a chicken's
blood gushes out of his wound flowing
down his forehead ears and and and
dripping from his chin the woman raises
the hammer again I almost feel pity for
him but it is too late to let him go
it's too late to go back it's too late
for my parents in my country do you as
you hear those words and you obviously
wrote do you feel that moment you still
see it
yes it's some in wish you didn't see it
I spent so many years
wishing I never saw it but I saw it and
it's been imprinted indelibly into my
brain and I try many years to get it out
it's too late it was too late for them
and it was too late for me what's this
done to you um it's definitely left a
lifelong scar um the physical side of it
that I grew up very paranoid I grew up
very afraid I grew up with a lot of
hatred and I grew up one to hurt other
people um and that as I come to America
and met really nice people and learned
people really are terrific
really are kind and that they not mean
that they're not out to kill me
you got to heal that part but the part
that never healed its fact that I miss
my father I miss my mother
I miss my sister's and that never will
heal I'll go back and talk about all
those folks and all eyes first one hold
up this map
or for those who have never been in that
part of the world where is Cambodia and
how many people live there when you live
there Cambodia borders tight Vietnam
Laos and Thailand as they can see and
when I was there in 75 the population of
Cambodia was proximately 7 million
people and where were you born
I was born in phenom penh the capital of
Cambodia what kind of a city is it um
the third world country it's a bustling
city I can remember just um in we have
tall buildings and however buildings
were a two three storey high only um
paved road some lots of vendors on the
streets it's just one of those some very
bustling city people wake up at 5:00 in
the morning this is very hot it can get
up to a hundred 110 degrees in the humid
and so people wake up very early and
then they set up shops on the side
streets and parents would go every day
because there are no refrigerators and
shop kids go to school and for me I
spent my name's playing hopscotch
outside of my house walking around and
I'm eating a lot of junk food one of my
favorite was some roasted cricket um and
my sis and I spent a lot of time just
playing ball and playing hopscotch on a
sidewalk you have up front in the book a
family chart from 1975 and you can see
on there your mother and father are
listed and your uncle and a couple of
your uncles but over here are your
brothers and sisters and I starts up at
the top the 18 year old yes where is he
he is in Vermont and he's living in
Vermont with his wife and two children
now coy the second one my second brother
is in Cambodia he's married and now has
six children give she didn't survive the
war Kim is has been living in France for
the last 13 years but the immigration
papers finally got processed and as of
this past Saturday he just moved to
Vermont to live with my brother in
Ming and Zhu is in Cambodia married with
five children and of course myself I'm
here in DC and gave my little sister did
not make the Twitter war she the first
to go she was um Ashley Nokia was the
first ago my older sister
how's your how did your older sister
died she was living at a war camp at
that moment I'm one of many war camps at
the kinder which had and um she was she
had AIDS some poisonous food and them
and her body just start giving out and I
think she had them I don't know what the
correct word is in English but she had
diarrhea and a lot of other poisoned
food symptoms and and they sent her to
infirmary and when we was hold about it
and when my father went when my parents
went to retrieve her she had already
died how old was she at the time she was
barely 15 and you were how old then I
was I was oh it's the nicest thing with
six and a half years old you know that a
lot of people who've written how about
the book wonder how you can remember all
this stuff in detail hmm how did you
reconstruct the story when was the first
time you did it for me it's a story that
wouldn't go away when I was um when I
was 16
Oh 15 I came to America as a
ten-year-old and in America I I didn't
want this I didn't want this face I
didn't want this mind I didn't want the
memory I wanted I want to be Jesse I
wanted to be an all-american girl I
wanted to be normal
I wanted amnesia um I played soccer hit
my head up with a ball so many times and
then I learned that getting a ninja in
real life is a lot more difficult than
on soap soap opera shows I was learning
English I watched ID liked other TV
shows and I succeeded in suppressing the
memory for the most part at night they
weren't nightmares during the day times
I was pretty well adjusted but when I
turned 15 around that age all of sudden
my body started developing alson I
wasn't a child anymore I couldn't hide
behind being a child
um and all and when that happened when
my body changed it did something to my
mind of some of the memory started came
flooding out and I didn't know what to
do with it it was the first time I went
through a severe depression I had I had
a nervous breakdown basically um I was
on a brink of suicide
I didn't didn't know what to do with and
there were no one to talk to there
weren't any other Cambodians there in
Vermont Essex Junction Vermont the
counselor I saw I felt like I was giving
more of a history lesson didn't feel
like I could talk to anybody and a
teacher of mine that mr. severance
encouraged me to write he encouraged me
to write because I wrote my story in an
essay and it came back with an A plus
plus plus on it without any red marks
for that and incorrect grammar and that
was the time I wrote that first draft I
wrote it six months later now I wrote it
through dinner I wrote it at night I
wrote in class I had over 200 pages of
handwritten Terios and most of that were
stream of consciousness writing and that
is really the first draft of the book I
took that journal and diary and I made
it into the book then turning into a
real book of course I've had to go a lot
and in look at the history I had to
restart it I went back to Cambodia four
times last year and talked to my
siblings and my cousin's my aunts
I had my brothers all contributed
informations my brother koi in Cambodia
were a hundred page approximately of our
history and our life in Khmer and then
my brother Maine in Vermont because I
don't I don't know how to write come
here very well he had to translate it
into English and in a way this um this
is a family project
couple things when you see the Khmer
Rouge what's that mean in English the
communist guerrilla group the communist
guerrilla group in in Cambodia that took
over the country in 1975 that defeated
the government in 1995 the London 11
mint so they were the red Cambodian
chimere's is Cambodian Rouge is red and
supposedly they were a color of red they
were called for passion meaning that
they loved us and they love the country
Cambodia is history includes ever being
a colony yes also French colony when it
was a French colony in the UM early 1900
yeah I don't forget fortunately I don't
have a specific date on my in LA
um for about I believe about 100-year in
the name Sanok we saw a lot of that back
in the 70s Prince Sienna who is he
he was the king he's now king of
Cambodia he was Prince of Cambodia then
he was um put in on the throne of being
king of Cambodia when he was at a young
age of 19
but then he abducted he abdicated his
throne to be Prince in order to work in
Politan to be involved in politics you
ever met him no you say in the early
part of the book that two million people
died yes how the Khmer Rouge during his
reign from April 17 1975 to the first
few weeks of January 79 in there three
years eight months and 21 days reign one
point five to two million people died
due to starvation disease forced labour
in execution why that's a really good
question I wish I knew the answer for
sure there are a lot of theories out
there the Khmer Rouge when they took
over the country in 1990 1975 I was in
pnom pen I was playing hopscotch and
remember just fighting with my sister
and playing hopscotch and one of the
other thing that my sister and I used to
do a lot wisdom in Cambodia is very hot
in a tropical country tropical country
there are a lot of black ants and one
thing that we used to do a lot was um we
would watch the ants march from one
place to another and as only ugly
children in any other country we had a
magnifier glass and we knew what to do
with it
and we would tilt it to the Sun when we
got bored and killed a few when the
commuters came into the country they
order everybody outside of the of the
cities to move to live in the
countryside non-fan at the time was a
popular city of a population of 2
million people I remember all of us
pouring into the street like black ants
being marched from one place to another
we didn't know where we were going to
end up we didn't know where we were
going and those would Pao were no longer
my sister and I would argue I go find
glasses they were soldiers with guns
standing on either side of us um and and
for us that was a four year death march
the Khmer Rouge moved everybody from the
city to live in a countryside because
they had hoped to build a country an
agricultural culture where everybody
would sign it would be classless and in
Catalyst people were made to work in the
field every day in our life or during
those years and first of all Cambodia at
that point was turned into a virtual
prison we didn't have walls but it was a
prison the labourers and the villages
that we live in were more like labour
camps in these camps every day was a
Monday every Monday a work day there was
no looking forward to hump day on
Wednesday there was no Friday there was
no Saturday there was no Sunday with no
holidays every day was work that each
work day 1216 hours and that was their
way of wanting to create an aquaculture
sighting and people were overworked and
they were not fed so they died due to
starvation who was Londo Londo was the
it was the government that was put into
power Wednesday and it was overthrow in
nineteen seventy and on this page and
you've got some photographs in here
there are people that I know you knew
well who are they
my father is some the loan the to loan
pictures on the on your left and this
picture of my mother and Chauncey she's
very beautiful and she was five eight
seven towers over most Cambodians and
was considering Amazon in our culture my
father and picture below
he was a captain in military police and
even during the London time worked as
the Royal Secret Service and then in the
right my picture of my mother on the
left with my with her sister and another
younger picture of my father which is um
picture on the left now what were your
parents doing when you all left that
first time from Phnom Penh to survive we
knew right away that we would be in
danger we knew right away cuz the
commuters culture at that time they only
value those the people who could
basically grow rice work in the land
those were the people had that had any
worth the rest of us were easily
destroyed didn't mean anything were
easily dispensable we knew we were in
danger because one of my father
political positions and in being a
military police we also knew you'd be in
danger because four part Chinese and
we're a lot lighter in skin and that we
were educated we all spoke a couple of
different languages and most of all we
didn't know how to work the land we
didn't know how to work the land we when
we left the country we hosed those
peasants we posed my father lied and
said that he wisdom he worked as a
person at the port carrying things one
place to another my mother was a seller
in the market we post those peasants and
higher identities in you say your middle
class at mu J it for instance and your
how big a home did you live in and Phnom
Penh we had a big house I mean of course
in in comparison to the US is probably a
small house but it was it was nice I
mean I had a bedroom that I shared with
my three sisters and my my brother had
their own bedrooms and we had a living
room we had a kitchen yes and we nice
stairs and tiles we had everything we
needed and want some picture there on
top who's in that that's my mother
holding a sister and my two brothers and
sitting is Michael
mother and my mother sister and brother
and that's in the home
yes did your parents have help was their
maid yes um and I was I was a very
spoiled child and them I I the only
thing I had to concern myself with was
going to school three times a day I went
to Chinese school I went to Khmer school
I went to French school and all the
chores we had some mains helpers to do
it all for us
what's this photograph up here uh that's
a great photograph that's um a picture
of my birth my three sisters my brother
and think just um
part one are you in this I am the
smallest one I'm the one with the
attitude it's um it brings me so much
joy to look at him because for 17 years
I never knew what I looked like as kid
we didn't have the only picture I had of
myself with 17 years in America was the
picture of the front cover of the book I
just picture right down here that's a
picture of my sister at my sister's and
I'm the one with without shoes and pants
were these photographs during your first
17 years they were um hidden we didn't
seventeen years I was in America um the
only picture I had of myself was a cover
of the book and it just looks a war torn
and ragged um that's the only picture I
could remember and depict it on picture
I had of me when I decided to turn to
write the book I went back to Cambodia
went back and talked to the villagers
and were able to find pictures some room
had couple of pictures and gave them to
us and my brother had gone back to the
apartment we lived in in Phnom Penh all
the people have moved in and since
claimed it to be their homes but um they
actually kept the pictures we left so
quickly that everything was still about
and when they came back and took the the
apartments um they kept the pictures
miraculous and gave it to us who's this
that's my sister - um when she was 18
and that was her on her wedding day
um looking beautiful and golden what was
when you left in 75 can you remember
leaving
yourself can you remember physically
walking out yes how far did you have to
walk eight days
I don't physically remember the days I
remember the walk um and my brothers
were able to fill me in with the days
and dates later I was five years old and
didn't want to walk I want to play I
want to walk when I want to walk I want
to run when I want to run but I did want
to go on on death march and how many
people were walking with you two million
people from Phnom Penh left in a span of
72 hours they emptied a city of 2
million people down to maybe a couple
thousand people who stay with the Khmer
Rouge and let's stay behind to do their
work did you know where you were going
now as far as I remember just as far as
I can see in front of me and behind me
there were always people they were
always um pots clanging against each
other kids crying people talking and the
shuffling of feet on gravel always
people dragging as far as as far as you
could see what were you wearing the same
outfit I wore for for seven days I am I
had on like a pair of yellow shorts and
shirts which turned gray after eight
days of not having a place to sleep in
and wash what would you eat in the
beginning my mother and father were very
very smart
even the Khmer who said to us to pack as
little as we can to sustain for three
days and then we can return my father
packed a lot of food he packed all the
rice we had and some canned food and and
other preserved meats we ate that for a
while but there were nine of us there
were nine of us and and we finally ran
out of food and whenever we stopped with
an evening my brother and in my father's
and other older siblings would just
browse the countryside for food and
picked berries and roots and whatever
they can find where did you end up we
end up in the first village cranked top
which was where my uncle
and aunts were living at and what was
life like there and how long did you
stay there we stayed there for a few
months
my uncle was considered part of the base
people group during the Khmer Rouge
regime people were separating to
basically two categories there were the
base people full-fledged citizen of the
commuter Society they were considered
the indispensable group they they it
being basement that they've always lived
in a countryside they've never lived in
the city to be corrupted by Western and
foreign influence and so they they were
considered to be the pure c'mere and
then there were the new people like
myself who all evacuated from the cities
and there were many other cities in
Cambodia and they were all evacuated so
my uncle had certain privilege in the
village because he was a base base he
was a base person when we first lived
there we of course pretended to be
peasants no one knew what we were really
were and every day my father would go
and my father mother and siblings would
go and worked in the field and my sister
and I would um went and take the cows to
pasture in the grass
how long before at what point in this
process did your sister die my sister
died um probably a year into the Khmer
Rouge she died it when we moved to
another village actually why did you
move to another village when new people
were always arriving and they were
always been being located and being
moved from one village to another and
every time a new family or new families
come into the village we always held our
breath you guys hope it's people we
didn't know and at one point someone
from this one new family that came into
the village River adds we actually
thought that we kind of knew them we
weren't sure they looked familiar but we
couldn't take the rest we could weren't
sure if they travel in the same circle
we did or live in Phnom Penh or if they
knew my father but we couldn't take the
rest and every time we thought someone
might come in that wouldn't recognize us
we would leave in order to go what was
the next village we went to the
village went to Rolly
how far away was that um didn't on the
truck and I think it took us a day to
get there and of course during this time
the whole time during the Khmer Rouge
regime for the four years calendar was
banned clocks any kind of machineries at
L times were banned radio TV newspaper
gatherings meetings so um and again
every day was a Monday we really didn't
know month month day to day and we could
only tell from the Sun the sky with a
moon position of the moon in the sky but
it took us a day to get there anything
when did your dad die hmm he um and how
old was he at that time was 42 he um he
died a year into it one year into being
a enrollee up yes
approximately one year um into it how
did it happen
we've been hiding we've been hiding and
we were pretty successful where it's and
you know I I was six um and we've been
living for about a year under his hiding
and safe and I got to a point I even
fools myself into thinking that maybe we
were safe it was complete shock when two
soldiers came and they asked for my
father they asked for my father and my
father asked why and they said um they
needed to take my they needed my father
to go with him to remove an oxcart of
the mud that was stalking and they were
traveling with and um we asked him when
my father was gonna come back and and
they said tomorrow he didn't come back
tomorrow he didn't come back the next
day we found out a few days later that
he was executed do you remember that
clearly remember that that whole
scenario uh I'm trying not to at the
moment yes
how do you I mean how often have you had
to tell a story quite a few times and
it's still hard yes it's so deathly hard
had do you want to tell the story I do I
do
um why I just didn't want to give them
my mind they might have one there bad
over for years they might have succeed
taking for my families but they're not
going to have my mind and how did you
fight this as did you even fight as a
five and six year old I mean they were
you conscious of this then yes um I was
conscious of wanting to live because my
father wanted me to live I want I was
conscious of wanting to do what he
wanted me to do um living um I don't
know if was ever I don't know I've ever
said to myself I'm gonna defeat them I'm
gonna win I'm gonna live certainly was
if something happened to me my parents
would be very sad it would be a betrayal
to my father he'll be a complete beater
with my father and God and I'm just too
hungry to even think about it so I'm
gonna go and get some food what was he
like um my father was um he was um a
great man it was he he loved me and I
was so wonderful I was kid what kept me
alive is I knew that my parents were so
completely in love with me of course and
I bet I was five years old and I'm in
the world of you all around me and I'm
sure a lot of all the children felt that
way but I was the six children of seven
my little sister was still a baby and
she was cute I was five I was cute
enough to be everybody's favorite I was
cute enough to know how to manipulate
people I was cute enough to know how to
be cute um and I was very well loved my
father
Lata was very special I'm sure everybody
everybody father thinks that but I
believed him because he always tells the
truth my father encouraged me to be
precocious and to be clever and
and to run around ask questions whereas
my mother always kind of worried about
me being able to grow up to be a proper
lady to speak properly to walk properly
to sit properly my father said you know
do whatever you want to do just have a
good time just come back at night don't
get lost what was the reaction to your
family when you knew that you'd lost
your father ah that night we waited it
was devastating
it was devastating cuz my father was the
brick of the family and he was he was
our strength
he was our mind he was the glue that
kept us together and them we didn't know
if we would be able to make it without
him so what you do um my brought my
older brothers were already at work
camps at that moment and my mother my
mother knew that and these demons had
discussions with my father and I know
she did they knew that that the Khmer
Rouge weren't going to stop at my father
they were going to go after all of us
they appear in a way it was such that
they were afraid the children of the
people they took away would rise up and
rebel and she knew that if we wanted to
survive we have to split and separate so
she gather all of the siblings together
those that were still there I was some
barely eight my sister was barely ten my
brother was barely 12 when my older
sister was was four and she said it's
time for you to go I don't want you I
can't have you here you go north you go
south to go east go west walk until you
get to an orphanage camp and by that
time there were many many orphanage
camps all around country when you get
there
change your name don't tell each other
don't come back I was so angry at her I
felt so I felt so rejected I felt that
my father loved me and wanted me and my
mother sent sending me away when I
needed her most um and I've gotten I
stayed angry with her for many many
years I stayed angry with her cuz I
thought was a weakness I thought it was
a weakness in writing the book I now
come to realize
that was an incredible act of courage to
send out your kids and not knowing into
the war zone and not knowing if they
would come back alive hurt torture but
you had to let him go for that slim
chance that they might live that was an
incredible courage and I have an adult I
have my place
um I can't can't imagine doing that but
it took me many years to understand that
I mean all I also understand in writing
that um and I didn't then that does a
mother she knew me and she must oh she
knew me a lot more a lot better than I
know myself and she knew the buttons to
push to make me go away to make me come
back and she must have known that if she
had shown any emotions and she had shown
any resistance to not wanting to send us
the way we would have cling to her
where'd you go um I ended up going to an
orphanage camp um and um na which one um
I originally I was first at a camp with
an orphanage down with my sister where
we worked in the field but then people
were always making fun of me and
taunting me and I got into a big fight
and the supervisor of the camp saw this
and loved it and loved it and then she
took me up and put me into civilian
military training came or lack of a
better word to describe it a child
soldier training camp um we didn't have
such words to describe it then all I
knew was that they saw the rage in me
they saw the hatred in me and they
wanted to foster that and so they took
the innate yeom they took me at that
time put me in the camp where they put
weapons into my hand knives guns axe
that's his hose and then they taught me
and it encouraged me to even be more
than to be even more hateful but go back
to when your mom wanted all those your
siblings to leave how many left um we
there were only four of us with her and
three of us left
the youngest one stayed behind with her
what's the name of the item cake GE a K
yes stick and that the three that left
yes who are they
game left and Joo and I left and this is
a picture from where this is a picture
in Cambodia um that's two men in the
middle and there yes that the one in the
white shirt with the black pants the
beautiful woman and them she's still
living in Cambodia and it's her children
the girl on the right and um and she's
still there and she's the one all stone
up the one that got married she's still
in Cambodia she and I left together
what was the religion of your family
we were Buddhist what did that mean for
us it means um I'm not a practices
practicing Buddhist at the moment I had
a lost faith when when my father was
killed but for my father and my family
meant that we as human beings or part
divine God is not something that's
outside of us God it's not something
that will come and save us we in within
ourselves can become God if we practice
Nirvana and practice our mind and
meditate when you were going through all
this back in the early years did your
family use the religion at all
my father did my father did I don't know
blianket day and I didn't remember
seeing my mother but my father religion
religion was banned so if you were
caught crisis and religion you were
persecuted or could be killed but every
once in a while I could see my father
going outside when when when it's dark
and sit on the knee on on the grass and
look up at the sky and meditate and pray
now go back again to when you were
dispersing where did you know how far
did you go from where your mother was
living at that time um I asked to me
that I must have been half a day's walk
away and again at that time there were
no clocks there were no calendar so the
only way I could tell time was position
of the Sun in the sky but I believe it's
probably half a day's why four or five
hours did you go by yourself at first I
went with my three brothers
my brother came in too and then came
split off and to and I just couldn't
separate so we stayed together and we
went to our first camp and we didn't
want to separate until the supervisor
saw that I that they want they wanted to
put me to another cam and she forced me
to leave how long were you in the labor
camps about a year and they trained you
to kill people they trained me to cable
enemies um an enemy meant everybody out
there that were against the government
besides from the physical training which
is fairly easy it's easy to put some
kind of weapon on a child's hand and say
do this and then I give you some food
it's Pavlovian conditioning but the
mental training the brainwashing that
went on forever every day many hours
each day that was that was hard to fight
sometimes that was hard to fight because
each morning and afternoon you would sit
and they would have all these propaganda
messages and then they would feel the
hatred and a lot of people believe that
in the hatred is that um we the children
of Cambodia were pure everybody else out
there were corrupted the adults we were
pure we were going to be the savior of
the anka of the community more Khmer
Rouge government and that we were
everything that we were the most special
and because of that because we're the
future of the government because
everybody knew that we were going to be
the ones to take the government to a
higher place they were all going to try
and kill us now Cambodia is we showed on
the map is in the middle of Thailand on
one side Vietnam on the other Laos up
above did you see any Lao or Vietnamese
or Thai people in Cambodia during this
time a lot in the village hi was that
and how you say your family was but part
part Chinese how much Chinese anything
my father um is half Chinese and my
mother's full Chinese born in China my
mother was born in China yes and how
many different skin colors are there in
a place like Cambodia
um before the war there were a lots of
different skin calm they were definitely
Thai there there were a lot of
Vietnamese there and a lot of just
mixed-race people but you talk about
your lights can we like uh would people
be very dark they will be much darker
they would have curlier hair and you can
recognize a Cambodian or Pio raised
Cambodian than the rest of us they would
have a lot of a lot of Chimaera would
have darker lips wider features fuller
features where I think the Chinese
mutinies tend to have a smaller see more
slender face and of course is the skin
color but that got harder - harder
harder and harder to recognize the two
specific reason one we were out in the
Sun every day ten hours a day so we all
got darken and - by years later on a lot
of the Chinese and a lot of Vietnamese
were executed they were the first school
to be executed how tall are you today by
two and if when you go back to Cambodia
is five - tall or shorter how does it
fit in it's pretty tall it's pretty yeah
in Cambodia in Cambodia i'm ashleigh
taller dandumb um that's denied and for
the most part they were people that told
me but I feel I feel a little bigger um
my mother was five six and my five seven
my my uncle on my parents eyes were 510
511 and I think I think the worst undid
our growth most definitely was there a
discrimination inside Cambodia based on
skin color when you lived there um
before the war they were probably I did
I didn't remember it because I was part
of the privileged class them and of
course we also had more money in that
you tend to not see the other side of
life during the Khmer Rouge there was
definitely discriminations I was called
that I was teased a lot and taunted a
lot by the other Khmer children because
I had see I had a lighter skin there
were times when I would just try and
darken my skin with mud and try to put
mud in my hair so that I would appear
more Khmer
and less Chinese now you your mother and
father and seven kids in the family yes
he lost your sister I lost one sister I
lost Gayle
once the circum and then you lost your
father
I lost my father my mother and another
young sister dick go to the situation
with your mother when did your mother
die and under what circumstances my when
I left the village when she sent me away
and forced me to go away actually I went
to an orphanage camp um and I just
remember one situation I think it's
probably um a year after I left I just
remember feeling just something wrong my
body was crying out there was just it
was just paying my mind was just I'm
hurting and I snuck out of my camp and I
went to see her in a village and I found
out that the Khmer Rouge soldiers had
come and taken her and my little sister
do you know why um I'm assuming because
they they are the real reason they took
so many people they were maybe put the
connections with my father maybe was
because of my father maybe she wasn't
contributing enough to working in a
field maybe my little sister cried too
much maybe they were sickly anyway and
so that soldiers in the government
didn't want to have to go on feeding
them if they're not working in the field
I don't know are you sure that that both
your mother and father are dead
yes how do you know I haven't found
their bodies we don't know what happened
to them for sure I know they loved us
we were their world they would have done
anything for us there's no way in hell
that if they lived 20 years later ten
years later five months later but they
would not cross hell they would not
cross landmines they would not cross
fire zones to get back to us what was
the impact on you when you lost your
mother and your little sister um I
remembers going there and when I found
out the news I
I had done what scientists call what
psychologists call future amnesia I lost
three days of my life I just blanked out
it was um was those like my mind to shut
down and and I and I cease to be Who I
am today just my mind shut down I
blanked out
it almost as if I went to sleep and I
woke up three days later and I'm back at
the camp I don't remember what happens
what happened to your life after that I
got a lot more angry I got a lot more
angry how would we have known if we'd
have been around you then that you're
angry um I would have hurt you
I would have hurt you physically yeah in
what way um I like to say that I
couldn't kill I like to say I couldn't
kill but I would have but I could did
you ever kill anybody
no I was very fortunate I was young they
trained me they trained me so that I
would grow up to be the perfect citizen
in mind and body um I was lucky I was
lucky I was never put in the front line
I was too young
um but I would have I could have so what
happened to you that where'd you go um I
stayed at the orphanage camp in and was
trained and stayed here for for a year
and just worked and live and got angrier
and angrier how dull was in the viennese
invaded Cambodia and of course um and in
my orphanage camp got bombed got bomb it
went into flames and um and that was a
sign for me to take off and escape and
run and I did I'm not sure I pronounced
it right but there's a friend of yours
is it Kathy yes that's where you
pronounce it yes poppy what's the story
about her uh she was my first friend in
four years for four years learning khmer
rouge she couldn't trust anybody
you couldn't have friends and she was my
first friend she was nine years old
maybe ten we were hiding out in a bomb
shelter and she was just right next to
me she was just crouching right next to
me and our shelter got hit and of course
instinctually with your hand you reach
for your head or you reach people and I
reached for her and instead of where her
head should be there was now a hole she
got hit by I don't know what the word
isn't me it's track now I think or a big
piece of it and and there was her blood
on me and in parts of her brains and I
got up and ran away I know I've asked
this question more than once but again
what you know when you think back to
that how do you process this stuff you
saw all this including that that
execution that you were very close to me
newer then how far away from that
execution gosh 40 30 feet if even maybe
last I was very close I was very close
but I had I had my grandma had my scarf
up forever my on my head so you could
even you only see my eye the fear of
living for four years fearing for your
life even though he was in a chair he
was tied up they were hundreds of Aust
surrounding him in my mind I was they
were friend I had to cover my face I was
afraid it what if he escaped what if
somehow he got loosen from the chair and
escaped and he sees my faces and come
after me and how many people were
surrounding him hundreds hundreds of
people and he again was a Khmer Rouge
she was a Khmer Rouge remember and oh
I'm assuming probably mid-20s just the
only one of these executions you saw
that I can remember
I mean you write again I wrote I read
some of this earlier been later on after
he first been hit over the head and
killed with a hammer there's another
person there with a knife who was that
um it's another one it was a public
execution the way they open it up with
them the leader of the group of the
Cambodian group asked volunteers from
the crowd to come and kill the man and
two women volunteer and after he was
killed
the women went up and and stabbed him
and supposedly allegedly she knew him he
was a Khmer Rouge member in our village
and he was um he was the one that killed
her family I want to read this again
only able to show how you wrote and
asked you by the way where where did you
write this book here in DC um in um my
in my house and in in my office
um sometimes when I couldn't when I
couldn't put it away it was I was
obsessive I was listening to Cambodian
music all the time I was um I was either
gonna write and do this final battle
well I was just gonna die trying
blood splatters the woman's clothes body
face she screams and swings the hammer
up above her head again blood droplets
land on my pants and face I wiped them
off red red smudges are still on my
palms another scream comes from the old
woman this time her hammer smashes his
leg his leg jerks but is held down by a
rope the hammer lands over and over
again on his arm shoulders and knees
before the younger woman moves toward
him taking her knife she pushes it into
the prisoner stomach more blood pours
out spilling over his chair she stabs
him again this time in the chest is it
hard to write that kind I wish I didn't
have to why did you want to put that in
the book the book I think I've been
writing it I think I was very restrained
with the violence um that is just one
sections where it was just fact it was
just there um I am I made it I made it a
focus to write a family story to write
about grace and dignity that people as
human being can live even in the most
extreme circumstances whether you can
live you live life with that certain
dignity for 24 hours 24 days or a month
that you can do it um and that was that
was just fact I actually read it because
then you're right this is not what this
book is like I read it because it was so
unusual isn't the book and wondered why
you had gone there
yeah um it was there it was there I went
there because it was there it was in
front of me blood splatter on me um and
it's in my mind how did you get out of
it Vietnam out of Cambodia um in in the
80s they were that wave of both people
coming into Thailand and um so we my
oldest brother and I um got ourselves on
a boat and went from the Cambodia to
Vietnam Vietnam to the refugee camp in
Thailand and then what I was the process
work how did you end up in Essex
Junction Vermont um guys we were at the
camp for a few months and I guess the
process that that you come they take
your pictures like the one on the cover
of the book and then they put the
pictures in refugee resettlement
programs all the world and people
sponsored you over and um we were there
for about five months and and um if we
didn't have a choice
we didn't have a choice we didn't know
anything about America we didn't speak
any English we didn't have any contacts
in America didn't know anybody from
America and so we didn't have a choice
it's just a matter of putting on marking
on on the refugee paper that you want to
leave we didn't even know if we were
going to end up in America in France in
Australia and we were sponsored by a
church the Holy Family Church group in
in Essex Junction and I remember some
remember the missionaries would come in
and show us the movies and I think I
already said it the movies were all were
all about San Francisco la New York and
I asked my brother is our new home to me
like that and we all will all were sure
that it was going to be like those
places we were in a complete shock shock
when we landed in Essex Junction Vermont
when you landed there who met you um our
sponsors our sponsors our Costello's to
loosen teams other members of the church
group and I was got I remember my
brother had bought me a white shirt
crisp white shirt that we folded and and
I put it on so quickly that the buttons
were button wrong when I got off the
plane they were just blast
of cameras and it was a little scary it
was a little scary what language did you
speak come here my brother's spoke uh
here at that time he already knew
English a little bit um but I didn't
know a single word I might know my ABCs
and thank you but I didn't know a single
word where did you go to live we lived
in Essex Junction Vermont and we live in
an apartment on the above the dentist's
office
with my brother and sister-in-law he was
just um 22 us aw it's just the three of
you living that's what the way of us
yeah and when did you learn English all
that summer we arrived on June 20th 1980
um
it's freezing I remember just being so
cold and it was June Christian in
Vermont is cold still and um we I
learned English all that summer I and of
course I learned spoken English we watch
TV we watch TV every day watch this
Jetsons
i watch Gilligan's Island I want a lot
of soap Robbins um and that's how we
learn but when I went to school um and
in a teacher and well the first
assignment in school was that we had to
write in our journal those little square
vanilla folder journal what we did
during the summer I didn't know the
language there was a girl named Barbara
I still remember sitting next to me she
wrote something and I copied what she
wrote
when we handed in to the teacher the
teacher called me over and said so you
wrote that your grandmother came to
visit and I said sure I've been in the
war I'm taught not to ever disagree with
adults and she said so you wrote you got
a dog and you went swimming and you went
to Disney World and I said okay if you
say so and it was then that they found
that I even know how to write they took
me out of the third grade put me in the
third grade put me in the second grade
and they had teachers coming in and
taking me out of class and then they
just kept moving me up grades until I
caught up and I was - I still graduated
a year behind but I caught it pretty
quickly yeah we talked about a little
bit about st. Michael's College which by
the way is located where
Vinu ski Vermont but I want to jump
before we run out of time to the
campaign for a landmine free world where
you work now full-time yes how long have
you done that for about three years I'm
the spokesperson for the campaign for
landline free world and I got involved
because for one Senator Leahy and
Senator Patrick Leahy he's our great
senator from Vermont when I landed in
Vermont it was such a blessing to know
that I read the papers and know that we
had a senator that knew and we're
concerned with human rights and was
working a lot with land mines and he
created the Leahy war Victims Fund that
assisted victims were hurt by land mines
in all parts of the world and so I knew
about land mines when I went back in
nineteen ninety ninety-five the first
time I just came face-to-face with this
the devastation that land mines are
still causing all over my country where
is this picture from that's not a
picture of me at ankle want just me
sitting contemplating and this was done
by a friend of mine who just happened to
walk by and catting and caught the
moments what year um this was actually
last year and and and I love the picture
because the little girl just reminded me
so much of me um in all parts of
Cambodia you couldn't go to a hospital
you couldn't go to a museum you couldn't
go to a movie theater you couldn't go to
a shop you couldn't go to a bar without
running into an amputee there's supposed
to be four to six million landmines
still in Cambodia and that is the war of
the second generation in Cambodia it is
no longer two soldiers that are killing
parents killing children making children
orphans is now landmines that is new
soldiers have you ever thought about
moving back permanently to Cambodia I
thought about it um definitely gonna be
going a lot um I don't America is my
home I love America um but Cambodia is
my heart it's my heart it's my
conscience
Kim Bodi design helps me design what's
right and what's wrong and what actions
to take I don't think I can live in
Cambodia it's um I'm too outspoken
politically and personally and otherwise
and they still this paranoia in my mind
that my family live in a small
villains I don't ever involve them with
my work when I'm in Cambodia working I
don't see them I don't call them I don't
talk to them when I'm finished I
disappear and I go visit them I'm afraid
that I'm there and I say the wrong
things I'm out in the public that I
might put them in danger whether that's
real or imagined I fear it you ever get
tired of telling the story um only the
people who only the people who just
doesn't really care and they're just
asking to be um I think sometimes people
um actually now I mean I I told the
stories and it's actually quite um for
lack of a better term their therapeutic
for me um each time I tell it I feel
less trapped by it each time I tell it
it's almost as if I release it into the
air a lot more and get it out of my mind
so that it doesn't control my mind it's
not a cloud hovering my mind and and
that I wear like a better hat um each
time I tell it I release it I release it
to out there I really sit out to the
world for people to sharing for people
to get and for people understand do you
happen to know how many Cambodians are
in the United States I think about
250,000 50 um 200 and a little over 200
thousand you know we're the largest
groups are located in Seattle um in
Lowell Massachusetts Rhode Island
Minnesota um
and California LA this is the cover of
the book and the title is first they
killed my father
blue and on our guests thank you very
much
thank you